foreign
Malachi's with us in Princeton Kentucky
hey Malachi what's up
uh yes thank you for having me on your
show Dave sure how can we help my my
question about it is is I finished baby
step one now I'm on baby step two
I'm actually moving away
um
I'm going
back to uh my hometown and
my ex-wife I co-signed with
um on her student loans and on her car
the student loans are 7 621 they have
offered me that's gone to collection
they've offered me a five thousand
dollar payoff
and if I were to do that first instead
of taking care of my smaller loans which
I know that you say you know you pay
your smallest loans off and you move on
to the next the Max and the next
but
would you you have five thousand do you
have five thousand dollars
say again yeah five thousand dollars
it's five I do not where are you gonna
get it you're gonna have to pay it all
at once
okay because the offer is not paying
power to get because if I were to get
that off you don't have five thousand
dollars
yeah these deals only work and they're
usually for a limited time for a lump
sum for a lump sum
yeah because I'm I'm whenever I'm moving
I'm looking for my full-time job right
now
um but I've already got my part-time job
lined up I'm in the National Guard I've
been in there since 2018. yeah so I'm
gonna be pulling three jobs getting my
kids every weekend because I'm paying
1200 a month in child support
and
we used to I actually I took your class
in high school
um I had ten thousand dollars I had 800
and
30 credit scores
and so you must have not learned
anything in my class okay
yeah well I had um
I got with a girl and she I got her
pregnant and um
now I have three kids
and now we're divorced I've actually
been separated since July it got
finalized in February I'm sorry um
uh I got this new place in um in
November and I've had to ask for money
from
family members and stuff like that
because all this debt that we had racked
up
um for the life that she had wanted and
the divorce decree was she supposed to
pay the car and her student loan
um actually my lawyers and her
negotiated
um because it was so much for the
student loans I'm responsible for half
for half of the seven thousand because
her car would be refinanced after that
got out of collection into her name
completely and that would get us a car
out of your name okay yeah so yeah yes
yes you do need yes you do need to pay
the student loan and yes you do need to
negotiate a lump sum when you have a
lump sum but right now Malachi you don't
have any money
yeah because I'm actually I'm moving
back into my parents home so right now
what you're going to do is you're going
to get on a detailed budget you're going
to live on nothing you're not going to
go out at night at all you're going to
work all the time and you're going to
start paying these debts off and when
you can get enough debt paid off that
you you know you pay off the little ones
and that'll get you more cash flow
because you're paying payments on all
this crap except her loan you're not
paying on her loan actually I am sir
I thought you said it was in delinquency
it is
um
here lately I've been I've been directly
sending it to her yeah so stop her house
yeah so stop sending her money and stop
sending student loan people money tell
them where she lives
yes sir they already know yeah tell them
tell them to call her
they're hounding me I know just tell
them jumping a creek you're not paying
it
I'm broke okay I'm broke I'm divorced
and I'm broke I don't have any money I'm
not paying it I'll pay it when I've got
some money how much other debt have you
got not counting this mess
um I've gotten down from or I right now
as of uh today I have 410 and 1 or 410
yeah and one credit card uh 239 in
another the car that I originally bought
for her that I got throughout the
divorce is 13 354.
um so twenty thousand dollars twenty
thousand dollars makes you debt free
I want you to go make twenty thousand
dollars in the next six months extra and
be a hundred percent debt free
and cut up your credit cards you cut up
your credit cards your car her student
loans
everything completely different I want
you to work like a maniac right now you
this is all happening to you and I'm
trying to get you to happen to it there
is not a technique that fixes this
except money and you get money from
working more
yes sir and that's what I'm that's what
I'm doing I'm actually you're about to
start but if you don't have any money
right now and you don't even have a job
right now
yes sir I've I've been on contact with
phones I've already got one part-time
job there you go that I'm going to be
doing after my full-time job good I'm
doing the National Guard and I'm gonna I
just got done with the interview today
as soon as all this money starts coming
in pay off those little credit cards and
then save up five thousand dollars and
call the student loan people and offer
them five thousand dollar lump sum until
then don't give them any money
that offer is going to continue to be
good yeah I mean it's in collections now
just call them up and go I can give you
five thousand now if it's two months
from now uh they'll take it all right
and then that clears that then all you
got left after that's your car
and then I want you to pay that off in
about three months and really you should
be debt free in six months you're living
at your parents house you got no
overhead it only takes twenty thousand
dollars to pay off everything but all
this crap has been happening to you
divorce kids a lot job loss people
calling you and hounding you
everything's happening to you and it's
time for you to stand up and happen to
it
and start telling this money and these
people what to do instead of doing what
they say to do it's time for you to bust
this thing in the nose and you're about
ready to do it I can hear it but I'm
telling you this is how you get after it
get it get it